okay let's go back to the phones at
617-830-4750
starting with our caller from the 202
area code who's calling today from 202.
hi can you hear me yes who's this hi
david um my name is eleanor and i'm
calling from the dc area
a long time listener first time caller
love it and
thanks i'm wondering if you have any
advice for where i should put my focus
uh the next few months leading up to the
election
i have some friends who say they won't
vote for biden
uh for various reasons either because
they're unsatisfied
with the fact that he is not um
adopting enough or adopt smart adopting
enough uh progressive policies in his
platform others say
uh because of uh the allegations against
him they feel
they can't vote for him hold on
what allegations uh sorry uh tara reid
allegations
oh you you have friends who are saying
now in
in september that they can't vote for
biden because of the terror read
allegations
yes uh wow and so i
for all these reasons i don't want to
have to
debate that with them
um but so i'm wondering if i should even
try and talk to them
or if i should uh because i am getting
involved with
um organizing programs in other states
right
swing states like pennsylvania and
michigan so should i just put my energy
there
well i was going to say eleanor these
friends of yours that they don't want to
vote for biden because
of tara reid's allegations what where
are they voting
uh so like i said i'm in the dc area
mostly there so
but i do have some friends from college
i went to a college in a swing state
and uh so listen we've got we've got
weeks left until this election
i would not waste any time arguing with
people who are voting in washington dc
number one washington dc is going to go
overwhelmingly to joe biden
it's an exercise in futility and
frustration so right off the bat
save yourself the time chop that
completely out of out of what you're
working on now
virginia's interesting i think that
there may be maybe there's an
opportunity to get involved in virginia
but the truth is that right now with
phone banking
you can decide to help in any state you
want to help in if you want to if you
look at
the georgia numbers and you say wow
george is closer than it normally is
i'm going to help phone bank in georgia
to get out the vote
because it'll force trump to have to
spend resources there
maybe you do that maybe you say well
wisconsin is a likely state to be the
difference maker
electorally i'm going to phone bank
there i wouldn't waste my time arguing
with dc voters who aren't going to vote
for biden i just wouldn't i think it's a
waste
of time right and
okay that makes sense yeah so thank you
so much i do really appreciate your
advice
and uh because that i have been getting
involved in programs in say pennsylvania
and michigan so i'll just keep doing
that beautiful
all right have a great day thanks
eleanor appreciate the phone call yeah i
mean listen guys at this point i don't
know that i
when half the country doesn't vote i
don't know that i'd be arguing with
anyone
even in the key states don't argue with
people
just identify the people who don't like
trump and explain to them how important
it is to vote and how easy it can be to
vote i think that's a much better uh
investment of time